you know you're what 30 trillion cells
60 trillion cells you know the number
keeps changing I would say the current
estimates that should be such an easy
cash I know but 30 trillion is here 32
yep okay how did that result and and
what 250 adult cell types a estimate as
as far as we know as far as we know okay
that all started from a single
fertilized egg which is I mean it
doesn't get better than this now
okay so miracle so how does that thing
have the information largely to become
you
well it didn't that's a process of
unpacking the consequences of a very
simple seeming initial object I have an
innocuous fertilized egg what could it
possibly become nobody would ever guess
that it would become you right from
first principles right so that was part
of what I was trying to do with with a
theory of everything is like is there
anything that unpacks into something
that has the richness of our world is
there anything with almost no evidence
structure whose consequence is us
because there's tons of evidence
directions ok that's beautiful I've
never heard you say that before but it
dovetails exactly ok